I was opening now you're in London just
The Love Actually reaction get bigger in
London it's sort of live actually so
much bigger than I ever thought it would
ever be or any of us did that it it's
sort of a universal sort of connection
that people have with them but it's
turned into a kind of an annual
Christmas movie people watch Love
Actually yeah but but people feel sorry
for you they feel very sorry for me but
they shouldn't it shouldn't because I
really believe I got the best kiss in
that movie hands down rodrigo santoro
[Applause]
hey wait and it was sweet because we
were both very brokenhearted when we
made that movie he had just been dumped
I had just been dumped and we I remember
the day we were going to go shoot this
thing we both sort of slumped in the van
[Music]
like well all day long we get to make
each other feel better and I think there
is a sweetness to the scene because of
that we were both we were both very much
all watch it again now
[Music]
you